good morning thank you all for being
here this morning
i want to take some time to speak
directly to nevadans after yesterday's
economic forum
which determines revenue projections
that the legislature can use to finalize
our state's budget
for the next biennium and nevada
i'm excited to say that after a long
year fighting this historic crisis
i have good news to deliver today in the
last 14 months
we've taken action to strike a balance
between protecting the public health
and also protecting our fragile economy
thanks to the quick response
by state and federal leaders to soften
the effects of a nationwide shutdown
and because of the sacrifices that were
made by all nevadans
our fiscal situation has greatly
improved
across the state we work together to
find creative and smart solutions
and contribute to the promising outcomes
we heard in yesterday's economic forum
the increase in revenue projections
announced yesterday
along with the funding the state will be
receiving from the american rescue plan
will put us in a better position to
begin stabilizing the state's fiscal
situation
restoring critical services and getting
assistance in nevadans
most in need but we didn't get to where
we are today without weathering
an incredibly difficult year when we
joined
states across the country to issue a
stay-at-home order in an attempt
to save lives and prevent the
overwhelming of our hospital system
many nevadans were forced out of their
jobs through no fault of their own
businesses both small and large suffered
because of nevada's limited economic
structure
this crisis hit our state worse than any
other
and just like so many nevada families
the state's budget
took a dramatic turn in the pandemic
that's why in the summer i had to
convene a special session of the nevada
legislature
to close a 1.2 billion dollar budget
shortfall
which included depleting the state
savings account
called the rainy day fund in an effort
to continue providing
critical services but there's no doubt
about it
the state's ability to provide services
during this difficult time
was made even more difficult because of
the dramatic loss in revenue
and in december when the state was
putting together the draft budget for
the upcoming two years
we again were forced to propose tough
reductions to an already
strained budget and again we did
everything with what we had
to prioritize resources and services
for nevadans but every difficult
decision was rooted in a long-term
strategy
for economic recovery which has led us
to where we are today
while we were dealing with a constantly
evolving situation
we took prudent and responsible fiscal
measures to ensure our budgets
stayed balanced and that we focused on
serving nevadans
the stakes were high and the decisions
were tough
but i knew that eventually the day would
come where i could say to my fellow
nevadans
that method has paid off in nevada
that day is today yesterday's economic
forum
proved that our crisis management
strategic budgeting decisions
and most importantly the shared
sacrifices of every nevadan in the last
14 months
has resulted in the states having 586.2
million dollars more
than we thought we would have when we
first created this budget in december
586.2 million dollars
members of the economic forum many of
whom jokingly say they are often
delivering
doom and gloom news announced that they
are feeling confident about nevada's
economic recovery
in addition to the unbelievable increase
in projected revenue
state economists also highlighted other
signals of our economic recovery
including crediting the successful
rollout of covid19 vaccine
as one of the driving factors to cause
consumer confidence to jump
to a 14-month high the projected
increase in revenue for the state
is a signal of the start of our comeback
and it's no accident
we are on track to have all capacity and
economic restrictions in the state
lifted
by june 1st a full reopening of our
economic sector is less than a month
away
many conventions have announced their
plans to return
and our businesses are coming back but
while we celebrate this moment
we can't allow ourselves to forget the
struggles we faced
in the last 14 months and that's what i
want to talk about now
how we move forward knowing what we know
today
we have been at this point before where
we're slowly exiting a crisis
and beginning to see the light ahead and
what we've learned from the past is that
the decisions we make
now will determine how prepared we are
for the next challenge
how fiscally stable our state is how
much we can prevent
future generations from having to face
the tough decisions
we had to make in the last year so as we
plan how to utilize a new state funding
to our state
from increased revenue projections and
federal funding
we must remember that spending is easy
investing is hard
but investing in will always be worth it
nevada we have a once in a lifetime
opportunity to utilize the funding we
have to transform our state
but it will require us to break the
patterns of the past
and that's what i want to commit to
nevadans here in this moment
i commit i am committed to changing our
systems
our systemic issues that make nevada the
hardest hit state in the nation when
there's an economic downturn
so i'm asking leaders to take the
approach of responsible families
throughout the state who are also making
their comeback right now
the many nevadans who got their jobs
back and for the first time in a while
are taking home a paycheck to their
families i'm asking that we take
thoughtful approaches with our funding
the same way these families are families
are using their paychecks
to pay off their credit cards put some
money aside
and invest in repairs they had to delay
over the past year
instead they're stabilizing their
financial situations
to get back to normal we need to take
the same approach
we need to refill our savings account
pay off our debts
and restore the difficult cuts that we
suffered in areas like mental health
and education we need to bring our state
back to a baseline and we also need to
fix what's broken by investing in new
systems
including the one at dieter as we use
these funds to stabilize our state's
fiscal situation
in the immediate we then need to ensure
our recovery process
brings along every nevadan especially
those who have been the most negatively
impacted
by this pandemic yesterday's economic
forum
showed us that those in our state who
make the most were
impacted the least and those who make
the least were impacted the most
we will not recover if we do not use
these funds to build a state
that gives them every opportunity to
succeed
expanding child care helping small
businesses
investing in community-based services
there's no doubt nevadans are resilient
which has been proven repeatedly
throughout the ups and downs in our
state's history
when you're the state that usually is as
the hardest hit in the crisis
the people have no choice but to become
resilient
but i know nevadans are probably tired
of having to be resilient all the time
that's why i want to make our state more
resilient so residents
don't have to be before i close this
address
i want to take a moment to talk about
our covet 19 vaccine rollout
as i've mentioned the speed and
efficiency
that the vaccine rollout was a key
factor in the positive economic forecast
announced yesterday
as today as of today more than 45
percent of eligible nevadans
have initiated vaccination and more than
one-third of eligible nevadans
are fully vaccinated i want to encourage
all nevadans who may not have yet chosen
to get their covit 19 vaccine
to consider speaking to their pharmacist
or their physician
if you still have questions the vets can
also visit
envycovidfider.org to learn more
about the covid19 vaccine and to
schedule an appointment
vaccination just doesn't protect you
from covet 19
as an individual it also protects the
people around you
when you're fully vaccinated you're much
less likely to get infected
and much less likely to spread the virus
increasing the number of nevadans who
are vaccinated against covet 19
will help reduce the potential for more
nevadans to get sick
and die every shot in the arm puts us
one step
closer on our path to full recovery
thank you for your time today as always
i am so grateful to be your governor
and i look forward to the challenges
ahead to make sure we set nevada up for
success
for generations to come thank you go get
your vaccine
god bless